patrick sabatier comme on l'a dit c'est
un métier où l'on vit du désir des
autres où l'on vit dans le regard des
autres
je vais vous faire une interview miroir
[Applaudissements]
mais vous êtes baptiste est à fond ça
déboule à ton copain en israël ça quand
tu vas voir schéma piste à fond il va
bien brut et oui mais oui et en tunisie
c'est ce qu il ya un barbare fils qui
s'appelle bafiba bar gay bien alors donc
que penseriez-vous patrick sabatier
si vous étiez vu par votre père je pense
a plus rien votre mère et s'est bien
occupé de son père votre frère je peux
compter sur lui votre femme
il pense trop à la télé votre maîtresse
une doit dérange
y en a pas deux enfants on est journée
très souvent avec toi une semaine ce qui
fait beaucoup de vos enfants et les
chercher à l'école j'allais à l'école en
dehors du temps libre même à l'époque
vous aviez beaucoup de boulot vous
occupiez beaucoup de vos enfants c'est
vrai notre concierge bas que je n'oublie
pas osé de peine voilà bien le
percepteur que je n'oublie pas non plus
votre patron que je dois être très
exigeant un peu trop un
ouais et votre ancien patron le lait je
pense que ce que le même reproche c'est
d'avoir gagner trop d'argent sur tf1
ouais les bénévoles
[Applaudissements]
si vous étiez vu par le regard de votre
réalisateur vous diriez quoi
le temps n'efface pas tout votre
coiffeur
il n'est pas toujours bien coiffée ça va
pas toujours maître maquilleuse ils me
demandent plus de travail qu'avant ils
viennent couche aussi votre médecin
il vient me voir pas assez souvent notre
psy mais de ce nom c'est ça le problème
peut-être votre meilleure amie a plus
d'amis et puis d'argent que je suis je
crois on peut compter sur lui ouais
ouais et votre pire ennemi
on peut compter sur lui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
peu de bleu